he's one of the four snowy owls we have
played the hedwig character in harry
potter
bringing animals to set that rarely
happens anymore
the realism hollywood achieves in their
films is uncanny
especially when it comes to realistic
animals but we wanted to know what films
like the jungle book and planet of the
apes look like without all their cgi
ready to pull back the curtain with us
you don't play any
you just drop into a deeper sense of
yourself
we're wondering if cirque du soleil
performer terry notary ever imagined
he'd find a career in creature acting
when he first started out
either way it got him a job working
alongside harrison ford in the call of
the wild
he said play buck and i said i'm in in
the film
terry acted as the stand-in for buck he
would dress up in a motion suit and
perform the scenes alongside the actor
as buck
harrison said it really helped him make
eye contact and form a real connection
with the characters
he gave me someone to establish an
emotional relationship with
just look at how well terry can
replicate the movement of a dog
it's uncanny they're quite limited in
the way they actually
reach there's a lot of movie magic that
goes into creating the real magic in
harry potter
but people tend to overlook how
realistic they were able to make
voldemort's horcrux nagini look
nagini was part of more than 180 shots
of vfx in the deathly hallows films
they researched pythons and were able to
make a 3d version that mimicked its
movements
while filming actors were told where the
snake was meant to be
or they would be able to reference an
object that was meant to be nagini
it's amazing they were able to create
something arguably creepier than
voldemort into a whole realistic snake
i need to keep you safe rocket may be
able to talk but he's still a raccoon
what's a raccoon what's a raccoon it's
what you are stupid
which meant the vfx team on guardians of
the galaxy had to make sure they created
him
accurately basically he's composed of
multiple layers
a skeletal layer the muscle layer and an
outer layer where they really had to go
into detail with his fur
and snout as for the onset action they
would have replicas of both rocket
and groot to take reference from and for
the actors to work with
it's actually it's like cheating because
i get to improvise off of and they don't
get to respond
the vfx work in narnia was
ground-breaking
just look at how perfectly crafted aslan
was
in your world i have another name in the
early days of filming
they had a bust of a lion's head that
the actors would interact with
but the director just didn't think it
was working they brought in an actor and
put him
in a fake mane to stimulate a more real
experience
no matter how odd it looked for other
scenes they even built a life-size
animatronic to copy a lion's movements
everything else was added in with cgi
his dark materials took on the ginormous
task of bringing to life
50 animals in total how did they do it
they created these puppets and hired
professional puppeteers to act alongside
the actors
later on through 2 000 shots of vfx
they turned those puppets into the
perfected animals we see on screen
it's really wonderful and the puppeteers
here are so incredible there were even
weighted puppets for when actors carried
them around
the director wanted to make sure the
actors connected with the animals
they were an extension of the human
characters after all
performance or timing or rhythm in a
scene
is really really helpful we've all heard
and seen how similar apes can be to
humans but behind the scenes of war for
the planet of the apes
took that fact to a whole new level to
bring the apes to life the actors wore
motion capture suits that the editors
used to create the apes appearance later
on
adjust them and make the performance uh
readable to a human audience the
filmmakers wanted to make sure that they
captured the actors emotions
but didn't take away from the fact that
they were real apes
we're no experts but we're gonna say
they succeeded
all of the people in the film are people
but all of the animals are
done on a computer james corden's humor
plus the impeccable animation made for
the amazing peter rabbit
but the filmmakers had to make sure they
didn't get too carried away with the
animation
they wanted to keep the realism alive
they visited the sound stages before
filming with paper rabbits to visualize
how they would piece
everything together the paper rabbits
came back for filming but they were
joined by some sculpted versions of main
characters like peter
these weren't just for the actors but
helped the editors know how real fur
would reflect on camera
the jungle book vfx team went beyond the
bare necessities to create their animals
the filmmakers studied documentaries of
animals and their nuances and then used
those references to build the animals
from the ground
up like rocket raccoon they started all
the way from the most
inner layer to all the fur and feather
you see on screen
the little boy neil seti who plays
mowgli was the cherry
on top he was such a good actor and
delivered all his lines to hand puppets
that's not possible but they made it
possible
remember how we mentioned movie sets
don't bring in real animals anymore
well life of pie was the exception to
bring richard the tiger to life
they used a mix of real tigers and an
editing team
it was cool but made their job difficult
they had to make sure that the audience
wouldn't be able to tell the fake tiger
apart from the real one
natural to have the tiger on the boat
without anything really
being there people love to say leonardo
dicaprio had to wrestle a bear just to
win an oscar
but the truth is he was actually
wrestling stuntman glenn ennis wearing a
blue suit
the actual bear was added in later on
you might be disappointed it wasn't
actually a real bear but that doesn't
mean it wasn't tough on leo
according to glenn everyone on set
thought he was hurting leo
that's how intense things got i was the
bear and we're taught on day one don't
hurt the main
actor director john favreau and his crew
took a trip to kenya in order to study
the animals in their natural habitat and
collect footage for reference
when they got back they had the
animators don vr headsets and transport
themselves into the footage they had
shot in kenya
this way they were better able to create
the 3d models of our favorites like
simba and nala
with the help of vfx and ai they created
all the animals we see
on screen from scratch how powerful the
technology is now and and understanding
that you got to make sure you know what
you're watching
the doolittle crew didn't go as far as
kenya but they did take a trip to
amazing animals along with trainers they
studied the animals movements and were
actually able to catch digital scans of
the animals
to use for their animations in the
studio according to filmmakers the
hardest part was creating yoshi the
polar bear
as for robert downey jr and the rest of
the humans
they had to act out their scene with
models of the animals that were moved
around using
rigs set up all these environments to
house this
motley crew of creatures twilight didn't
have many animals but they did have
werewolves
jacob and his pack were all created
using cgi
however when bella was meant to have
emotional talks with jacob in his wolf
form
taylor lautner would put on a
funny-looking grey suit and act
alongside her
in this scene kristen stewart is
actually petting taylor
it was exciting for me um as an actor
because you're right he changes a lot in
this movie
we all know disney is a go big or go
home type of studio
so it isn't surprising they made a
life-size model of dumbo to use on set
for lighting references and placements
but they also hired creature performer
ed osmond who wore a green screen
spandex suit for his dumbo role
the themes and the emotions are very try
to be simple and human and relatable
jim carrey is a pro at animals
aceventure a pet detective anyone
so we're guessing his time on mr
popper's penguins was
easy as pie as stand-ins for the
penguins kerry would
carry around stuffed animals filled with
rice so it would mimic the proper
weights
as for the actual penguins we saw on
screen filmmakers used research from
biologists to understand how they looked
moved and reacted to certain things add
a dash of cgi
and voila penguins are kind of an
obsession with me i really i really love
them
it's so hard to believe that these cgi
experts are able to create animals from
scratch
it's actually magic a huge kudos goes
out to the actors who pulled off the
roles
perfectly a lot of them didn't exactly
have their acting partners present
that's what we call a professional what
behind the scenes look was the most
surprising to you